first a dr is actually not about what
we're going to look at but and ideas
very very common text to us which is
distance ok so what is distance simple
simple idea distance is just a length
that's been traveled right as opposed to
a length which has been measured right a
distance which is a life which you've
gone from one place to another ok so I'm
going to call I'm going to define
distance as a total length child ok now
once you understand that remember this
is about connecting and comparing these
different changing quantities so if we
say ok well distance that's a quantity
and it can change we call the change of
distance with respect to the change in
time we call that sleep so speed is
simply about we actually have this
triangle right which you've learned all
the way Baggins in stage four science
right which is distance over time yes
speed is the name that we give to the
comparison and change between distance
and time now the important thing you
need to understand here and there's a
big distinction between this and the
next to dot points which are parallel to
the important thing in here is that
direction doesn't matter I don't care
which direction you're facing you if
you're running running running running
running whichever you are facing you're
still traveling distance so therefore
you still have a speed of some kind ok
distance and therefore speed can be zero
or positive but there's no such thing as
negative speed or negative distance
right if you traveled in a direction and
you've traveled back you've just covered
more length ok so this irrespective of
directing but we want to be able to
flying over this and we have mathematics
to understand direction so if you add
direction to distance very connected i
do you know meaning that we call this
displacement ok so this place was
obviously connected to distance but like
i said it's more about
addition so I would describe
displacement as position as compared to
where you started position compared to
starting point okay now what this means
is if you're doing if you're running
laps of aluminum okay once you complete
a single lap you have gone a certain
distance right but once you've completed
that lap and started ended back where
you started your displacement at that
instant in time is zero because your
position compared to your starting point
is where you are exactly where you
started so you currently at that point
have zero displacement you have distance
you have a spin but you displacement is
zebra yeah your total displacement is
zero ok so this ID therefore if you
think about how distance is changing
over time we call at speed if you
thought about how displacement is this
is changing over time we call that
velocity okay so this is about change in
displacement over change in time
okay now to try and keep these
consistent with what we looked at before
um distance is about our location right
displacement is about a location so we
tend to give the name to this weekend to
call this our experiment right they
don't call a date because the tents
walking distance and X fits into our
coordinate system the only catch with
this is that if you're thinking about
how something is moving over time you've
got an x-axis and you've got a time axis
the x axis displacement at a time axis
now when we think about a normal set of
corn and axes right we usually have the
X is the horizontal thing and we call
the why the the vertical axis ry enactus
right it's just the other one okay but
since we pretty much universally think
about time going from left to right like
this is just like a chronological theme
because we read from left to right we
tend to call this axis the time axis
which means that X the displacement gets
put onto the vertical that's a bit weird
students confuse it's because they're
like wait I'm so use the XP horizontal
yes it might be horizontal but it could
just easily be vertical remember when I
talked about that book moving up and
down okay so this could be uptown could
be that's right whatever you want it's
about your position relative to where
you started okay now I should point out
see this right this is really a stated
about gradient yes this is like do I
over DX right because change what you're
really calculating over here is an
average velocity okay there's got to be
some change in time now we'll get to I
mean the fact that we have calculus
means I don't have to think about an
interval of time I can figure out the
instant of time and instant versus
interval but at the moment if there's a
change in time the time is past your
think you had the average for C over
that over that little time so how would
you actually calculate this while the
change of displacement you've got an x
value where you started and an x value
where you ended right so you'd say well
okay
I just want to compare those there's
just the change and in the same way
there's going to be a time that
corresponds to each of those
displacements so you want to work out
the change between those as well okay
and you will recognize this as the
gradient formula right y2 minus y1 and
x2 minus x1 it's just the time is our
horizontal axis that's why it's all
about it does that make sense okay now
like I said the difference between these
two things is whether you are interested
in direction or not okay so displacement
can be negative I can go in the opposite
direction from which way I'm facing okay
and it's the same thing with velocity so
here direction is important okay